the covert 19 pandemic has shaped the
lives of people around the world the
global lockdown is the single biggest
experiment in human history The
Economist has been reporting on the way
in which it's affecting everything from
the global economy to the way people
work travel and interact the fear for
many in countries emerging from lockdown
is that a second wave is just around the
corner I think the reality is that until
we have a vaccine and until that vaccine
is widely distributed we are going to
have more waves you submitted your
questions about a possible second wave
to Zanny Minton Beddoes our
editor-in-chief and Slava Chang cover a
healthcare correspondent here are their
answers in what ways will the second
wave be different to the first wave I
think the main way in which the second
wave is likely to be different to the
first wave is that it will be with luck
less Universal and more isolated
outbreaks and so focused on people and
places that are vulnerable that's right
and what will happen is that we'll see
outbreak outbreaks it may be easier to
contain especially in places that have
well-functioning testing and tracing
systems so they can quickly catch
outbreaks before they swell into a
second wave I think one thing that's
important to add though is that some
places have not yet finished the first
wave and so it's too early to talk about
a second wave but in those places where
we have seen the the rate of infection
come down where the our number has come
down the hope will be that any future
wave can be more controlled in two
particular places assuming a second wave
happens what is the likelihood that
people will comply with another lockdown
that's a very difficult question we are
already seeing that people have been
tired of lock downs they're not
following the rules they're letting
their guard down so it will be a
difficult task for governments to
convince them to comply with any further
restrictions that may be needed and of
course we'll probably see things vary
from country to country sound depends on
culture
some places may be more compliant than
others I think we'll also see
government's much more reluctant to try
and put in a wholesale lockdown because
they will have seen the economic
consequences in the economic costs of
that so I think they will try and be
much more targeted with any lockdowns
any shut bans and then whether people
comply or not depends on awful lot also
and whether they trust their government
can we expect further waves until we
reach herd immunity this is a you know a
disease that no one knew about six
months ago but the world is working the
world scientists are working incredibly
hard to find that vaccine until then we
are going to keep seeing it recurring I
think we probably see second waves in in
some places and it is of course the
government responsibility to watch out
for second waves starting to do what it
takes to prevent them to institute the
right measures but it's a joint
responsibility with their citizens in
making sure that those waves don't
happen and we as citizens must comply
with requests to stay home if you've
been exposed to someone known to be
infected that will be crucial to
containing the second wave the
quarantine of people who may be
infectious how can the world collaborate
to stop the spread of kovat 19 we are
already seeing an incredible degree of
collaboration on the science side there
are hundreds of hospitals around the
world which are gathering data in
real-time on what works best to treat
patients who are very sick with carbon
19 we are also seeing collaboration on
the vaccine development side with
outfits in several countries working
together to develop new vaccines so on
the science side it's really an
unprecedented collaboration right now
I'm impressed by the scientific
cooperation which is happening often
sort of behind the headlines but I'm
struck by how little multilateralism
there is beyond that I think going
forward one of the most important things
is how a country is going to be able to
coordinate travel for example safe
travel at the moment
have you know countries effectively
having shut their borders most countries
how are we going to be able to maintain
the flow of goods and services get back
to a normal that allows people to move
between countries and we haven't seen
that yet and I guess the other element
is how and and are richer country is
going to give more assistance and assist
more poorer countries that have been hit
in many ways by this what impact is
covered 19 having on elections in the
Democratic world well certainly would be
authoritarians have taken advantage of
curve in 19 and I think you see that
very much in Hungary ver where Viktor
Orban has passed a law had Parliament
passed a law which essentially allows
him to rule as a dictator and in many
other countries where you have not all
that democratic governments kind of
authoritarian regimes have been using
this to clamp down tamp down on press
freedom using much greater ability to
survey people are with the excuse that
you need to do that for for kind of
controlling the disease I think in in
democracies the real question one of the
most important questions is how
elections are going to be run and that's
obviously a huge question hanging over
the United States which has probably the
single most important election in the
world coming up in November and I think
there the question will be is the
country going to be in other states
going to be able to organize themselves
to hold an election that may be taking
place certainly at a time when people
still have to social distance but
possibly where there are in parts of the
country second waves it can be done the
question for me is whether the electoral
sort of machinery of the US can sort of
be got together in time to do that and
and I do worry that it not enough
attention is being focused on that what
will happen if another virus comes up
before we find a vaccine for covert 19
that's one for severe we are in trouble
we already seeing about the virus which
is quite deadly bite by the standards of
the flu and viruses we already have
circulating but it is possible that the
new one comes up at any time really
and it could be deadlier it may spread
more easily so it is upon the world to
learn the lesson from covet 19 very
quickly and do what it takes to prevent
another one from emerging and spreading
will the stock market decline again with
the second wave what is striking right
now is the extraordinary bounce-back
we've had particularly in u.s. stock
markets and the dissonance between that
and the sort of degree to which the
economy has been harmed now stock
markets are clearly forward looking
they're anticipating more stimulus and
they are anticipating a very rapid
recovery my own view is that we are
going to see a recovery but I think it's
not going to be to where we were before
the new normal if you will is going to
be a diminished economy and an economy
that needs a lot of restructuring as
some sectors whether it's tourism or
hospitality are less strong much less
strong than they were and take longer to
come back and others you know
particularly big tech companies for
example are doing extraordinarily well
so that restructuring I think means that
there's a lot more economic turmoil
ahead what do you think of the positive
effects of the pandemic one positive
thing that I think will come out of this
when it's all done and dusted is create
there flexibility in how people work and
that in turn will lead to a lot more
work-life balance balance heavier on the
life side I think for those people who
can work from home service sector
workers creative workers that work that
can be done from home that's absolutely
true but I think there are many jobs
that cannot be done from home and I
think this is going to in many ways to
increase the inequality of the labor
market between those people and often
that's low-skilled jobs where you have
to be at your job and people who can can
do their job from home and I think it's
also quite possibly going to be a lot
harder for entrance into the workforce I
mean I've noticed that you know the
economists it's amazing how Slava and
all of our other colleagues have have
been able to work incredibly
productively from her
and we're producing everything this film
is being produced completely remotely
but I think that there is a risk over
the long term that we lose something in
terms of sort of innovation and even
productivity because you don't have that
kind of serendipitous sharing of ideas
bumping into people in the office can
countries afford another long term
lockdown I think that's a really good
question and I think the answer probably
is no I think we've learnt that there
are huge economic costs that come from
complete lock downs and in general those
are costs that are even harder to bear
for less developed countries if you are
a an advanced economy it's possible to
do the huge amount of support fiscal
support monetary support that's needed
it's much harder if you're an emerging
economy both because social distancing
is harder and there isn't it's not as
easy to for the government to provide
the scale of support that's needed so I
would be very surprised if government's
tried again to do long full-scale lock
downs since the start of the pandemic we
at the economists have been trying hard
to keep you up to date with all aspects
of the pandemic and where it's going
from the economic risks to the health
risks you could read all of our coverage
by clicking the link opposite thanks for
all your questions and thanks for
watching